Tom Segura Kid toilet water again a bird
story wherever Chrysler came to my house
my six-year-old was five at the time he
had a cup of water he goes here you go
got you some water and Bert was like
okay
thanks he goes drink it but it was like
oh where'd you get it he's like from the
sink Bert goes well you have some first
and he goes no it's for you and Bert's
like did you get this like knot from the
sink and he goes no he goes did you get
this from the toilet and my kid goes no
and I'm sitting there watching this and
I go hey did you get this from the
toilet he goes no and I turned to my
friend I go I believe him and then he
goes I don't believe him and he won't
take it and my kid keeps going like so
at the time I go all right I just walked
to the bathroom I see a trail of water
from the toilet all the way out to where
he is and I go hey don't drink it don't
drink and I go out there and I go hey
man you got this from the toilet and he
goes I'm sorry and he just walks away I
was like man I have a couple little
psychos